uns ist nun der ehemalige berater des
vize präsidenten joe biden der jetzt der
präsident elect ist zugeschaltet und
zwar morgen besser ist sowohl als person
die auch als politiker was war ihre
erste reaktion
bestätigt wurde dass joe biden der
nächste präsident sein wird
zu merck samir danke dass sie mich
eingeladen haben
meine besten wünsche gehen an die
menschen und deutschland zunächst mal
führte ich eine riesige erleichterung
damit ja gar nicht dessen bewusst dass
ich vier jahre lang den atem anhielt zum
ersten mal konnte ich aufatmen ich
spürte diesen seufzer der erleichterung
rings um die welt also meine erste
reaktion war erleichterung und wieder
atmen können sehr viel glück und freude
schau dir uns aber jetzt mal die politik
an in deutschland spricht alle welt
davon liegen nun joe biden besser sein
wird dafür die transatlantische arbeit
für die politik
wie sehen sie dass die nächsten vier
jahre was wird joe biden verändern was
sind seine wichtigsten taten der dias
der wichtige tat von joe biden als
präsident soweit es deutschland und
andere freunde und verbünde gehandelt
wird darin bestehen unsere
freundschaften wieder aufzubauen
unsere beziehungen mit deutschland und
anderen ländern die beiden weiß es er
hat ja diese vielen jahr hätte
erfahrungen er weiß wie wichtig und
machtvolle starke verlässliche
verbündete und beziehungen sind
er wird diese beziehungen wieder
aufbauen so dass sie auf wechselseitigem
vertrauen beruhen auf wechselseitigem
respekt und dass es stets darin gelebte
arten der zusammenarbeit des
kompromisses zu finden so dass es sowohl
die menschen in deutschland wie auch in
den usa insgesamt besser dastehen was
ist der mensch was ist so seien der
politik habe ich mir niemals aus dem
nähkästchen geplaudert persönliche
geheimnisse gebe ich nicht preise mit
dem ich das projekt zu arbeiten hat doch
joe biden ist kein trinken keinen
alkohol
aber so viel kann ich sagen zu seinem
besten und klingende joe biden den sie
auf dem fernsehfilm dieser all leuchtete
geister dieser mine lichterloh und doch
auch mit liebe mit freundschaftlich kite
mit sanftmut gefüllt ist das ist genau
der joe biden der auch außerhalb der
bühne ist wenn die kameras ausgeschaltet
sind als privater mensch ist er genau
dieselbe authentische schöne seele vor
der kamera hinter der kamera
er ist einfach nur ein mensch in jedem
sinne
ich sage ihnen das als sein volk
ich spüre große liebe zu ihm ich
bewundere ich respektiere ihn ja weil er
eben dass es ein anständiger guter
mensch ich kann die dame nicht hören
ich habe irgendwie das audio verloren
belastungssituationen
ja ich habe das verstanden eigentlich
eine tolle frage zunächst einmal
emotional einer der vielen gründe
weshalb die beiden diese wahl gewonnen
hat und auch alle bisherigen rekorde
übertroffen hat einer der gründe ist ist
seine menschlichkeit
man kann mit ihm eine beziehung mit ihm
eingehen
man kommt an ihn heran auch sie in
deutschland es ist diese menschliche
seite wann er wird also selbst emotionen
verspüren und auch zeigen wenn sie das
auch und wir das spüren wenn zum
beispiel etwas tolles leistet oder wenn
er durch jemanden inspiriert wird dann
zeigt er dass auch ungewollt also er ist
ein offener menschen wenn etwas schönes
oder etwas trauriges geschieht er ist
ein mensch in seiner ganzen
menschlichkeit meiner meinung nach hat
er deswegen auch die wahl gewonnen und
deswegen hat die mehrheit der
amerikanischen bürger für ihn gestimmt
wie geht er in belastungssituationen
vor nun in diesen 49 jahren geht er mit
sanftmut um mit einer gewissen
verantwortlichkeit mit redlichkeit und
mit geschick das schönste bei seinen
belastungssituationen ist dass er
ehrlich ist er liegt jetzt nicht herum
er ist sehr offen aber es sehr nämlich
eher nicht gelassen gelassen geht er
seinen weg so sagen wir dass die man
kann natürlich mindestens eine sagten er
ist vorhersehbar nicht dieses chaote so
durcheinander dass wir erlebten diese
art achterbahnfahrt die wir erlebt haben
nein er hat echte gefühle
ich glaube das ist wirklich ein
herzliches willkommen wir haben einen
präsidenten der endlich mal gefühl hat
also das kann ich gar nicht erwarten
vorhersagbare ich glaube das ist etwas
gutes in der politik dem stimmen wir
wohl alle zu vielen dank für diesen
einblick in das leben von joe biden den
ex also bleiben sie alle gesund ich grüß
mehr nachrichten und bikinis nur weil
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergessen nichts abonnieren